now I want to apologize for this we've
been very busy doing these shows I did
not get to eat lunch today I didn't have
a chance so can I just take a sink with
you Joe could someone bring me out a
sandwich please I just want to I love to
eat thank you and thank you for bringing
them through those space-age doors yeah
it's great
you just applauded a sandwich
that's how good the comic-con crowds are
yeah sandwich in there it was wait a
minute this scene which is huge there's
no way I can eat this whole thing huh I
need to cut it in half and if you have a
knife they don't let me have knives okay
that's right me neither I guess I'll
just have to throw it in the trash I
mean there's nothing else they can do oh
just just a spruce you got it for you
you're right hey Bruce can you please
come out here
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up ginger well I need to cut the
sandwich I wonder if he could maybe give
me a hand
sure how about that hand yeah yeah you
better step back little girl all right
you crusty son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
Wow
thank you Bruce
Laurin tastic thank you you're welcome
you're welcome there's anything else you
need I'll be in my dressing room just
polishing the old blade if you know what
I mean
of course I mean masturbate
[Applause]
seizing a match vs. Evil Dead premiere
time starts this October